bilder aus schweden wollen wir zeigen
philippi ad hoc alter schwede vom abend
nämlich aus der nacht tolle feier bilder
aus stockholm aus göteborg und so weiter
und so fort bilder der freiheit die uns
erreichen vom abend dort von den straßen
absolut das sind wunderschöne bilder
ehrlich gesagt ich fand die bilder der
letzten anderthalb jahre aus schweden
auch schon wunderschön weil das immer
bilder der freiheit fahren und ich
berichte jetzt seit ca april 2020 über
den schwedischen weg also den anti
lockdown weg schweden hat ja kein
einziges mal irgendein lockdown gemacht
ja schön dass sie jetzt in freedom day
hatten aber auch schon vor wochen und
monaten hatten sie viel viel viel
lockere regeln als wir und wirklich wenn
man schweden verteidigt hat wurde man so
verspottet so kritisiert von der ostens
und lauterbachs dieser welt und jetzt
sieht man ja schweden hatte recht
schweden hatte einfach recht und warum
schaffen wir jetzt alle regeln ab nicht
weil sie eine impfquote von 100 prozent
haben deren im code ist minimal höher
als unsere die haben bei über
60-jährigen circa 84% erstimpfung quote
wir haben bei über 18 jährigen 78
prozent aber ganz ehrlich auch wenn wir
ein paar prozent darüber legen werden
wir es nicht machen wie die schweden es
ist eine frage nicht die frage von
impfzahlen überhaupt nicht die frage von
zahlen es ist die frage des gesunden
menschenverstands sie haben von anfang
an gesagt wenn wir einmal in den locker
angehen werden wir diesen automatismus
schaffen wir werden es immer wieder
machen müssen das hat mir der frühere
schwedische staatsbürger im april 2020
prophezeit gesagt ihr seid einmal den
locker angegangen und ihr werdet es
wieder und wieder und wieder machen
jedes mal wenn die verdammten incidents
ansteigen was ist passiert genau das
passiert in schweden konnten die kinder
immer zur schule gehen in schweden
konnten die menschen immer frei
entscheiden ob sie ins restaurant gehen
und das resultat ist ja schweden hat
etwas höhere todeszahlen pro einwohner
das liegt aber ausschließlich
ausschließlich an der ersten welle wo
sie es nicht geschafft haben die alten
heimat zu schützen wenn man sich aber
mal die sterblichkeit zahlen insgesamt
an schaut also nicht nur cooler sondern
überhaupt die sterblichkeitsraten ist
schweben im unteren europäischen
durchschnitt
[Musik]